la chronique de l'environnement bonsoir
Sophie intéresser à la qualité de l'eau
dans le département exactement il a
arrêté de pleuvoir mais nous on parle
d'eau
et vous en faut encore quelle est la
qualité de l'eau dans les Yvelines on va
essayer de répondre à cette question là
ce soir puisque l'Agence de l'eau c'est
Normandie vient de rendre une synthèse
provisoire du stage alors qu'est-ce que
c'est le stage c'est le schéma directeur
d'aménagement de gestion des eaux en
bref c'est un document qui va définir la
politique de l'eau dans les années à
venir c'est un établissement public
l'Agence de l'eau qui est sous tutelle
du ministère de l'écologie elle perçoit
des redevances c'est comme ça qu'elle
gagne de l'argent elle les reverse sous
forme d'aide et de subventions aux
collectivités territoriales aux
industriels aux agriculteurs qui
s'engagent à faire des travaux de façon
à lutter contre la pollution de l'eau en
chiffres rapidement ces 4,7 milliards
d'euros pour le bassin Seine Normandie
entre 2013 et 2008 2018 pardon par
exemple les conseillers généraux
viennent d'être invités par le préfet de
région a donné leur avis sur ce document
là c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
Jean-François bel vous êtes donc
vice-président du conseil général et
délégué à l'environnement bonsoir
bonsoir
le rapport donc porte sur le bassin
scène Normandie c'est une grosse région
nous on va s'intéresser plus
particulièrement aux Yvelines puisque
c'est ça qui nous concerne évidemment
l'eau est beaucoup présente dans les
Yvelines il y a par exemple 1000 km de
rivière on compte 800 hectares d'étang
et de plan d'eau au nord la Seine elle
traverse d'est en ouest le département
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ce rapport sur
le la qualité de l'eau dans notre
département pour commencer peut mieux
faire voilà ce qu'il dit en fait le
rapport tel qu'il nous a été présenté a
été approuvé à l'unanimité par les
conseillers généraux toutes tendances
confondues il est vrai qu'il s'agit
principalement d'un sujet technique
alors l'eau dans les Yvelines on doit
dist l'eau de nos rivière de l'eau que
l'on boit Paulo rivière nous sommes dans
le cadre du sidage chez ma directeur
d'aménagement et de gestion de l'eau qui
est réalisé tous les 6 ans
l'échéance prochaine c'est 2015 et pour
2015 il faut que les deux tiers de nos
rivières soient dans un état
correct tant sur le plan chimique que ce
plan biologique parce qu'il faut se
mettre aux normes européennes
ensuite les champs suivantes sera 2021
et enfin l'ultime échéance 2027 où il
faudra que tout soit parfait je pense
que dans le département nous on
progresse énormément on progresse mais
pour l'instant ça va pas trop trop bien
non plus il y a des chiffres qui sont un
petit peu inquiétants je vous propose
de les voir ensemble moi j'ai noté sur
un document de l'Agence de l'eau qui est
un rapport annuel de 2012
qu'il y avait par exemple là on le voit
sur le graphique c'est c'est tout à
droite il y a 38% des des masses d'eau
qui sont au-dessus du seuil de des
normes en nitrate et pesticides où on
dit qu'il va falloir voir une action
renforcée ça ça paraît un petit peu
inquiétant ce chiffre là par exemple oui
mais
nitrate ça dépend sous quelle forme nous
avons une trace je pense que sur une
nitrates on progresse énormément à
l'heure actuelle le fait d'avoir les
deux tiers des stations d'épuration qui
ont été entièrement rénovés nous
permettent d'avoir des sorties de
station qui sont en bien meilleure
qualité il est cependant vrai que la
principale source de pollution notamment
de la scène c'est notre énorme station
d'épuration d'Achères qui est la plus
grande d'Europe et qui elle
était une passoire puisqu'elle n'était
efficace qu'à 40% depuis
son azote
dans la scène tout simplement
2012 donc
là
il y a un effet le tampon il faut un peu
de temps pour que les analyses
s'améliorent mais je pense qu'elles vont
s'améliorer dans le temps il est
indéniable qu'il y a encore des progrès
à faire mais au point de vue qualité
d'énormes progrès ont été faits je
prends l'exemple de la CNL même vous
savez il y a 20 ans il y avait trois
espèces de poissons aujourd'hui il y en
a 36 quant à l'industriel pollue la
scène autrefois il n'y avait pas de
poisson les ventres en l'air maintenant
il y en a et donc je crois que peu à peu
on est vraiment en train d'améliorer des
choses vous pensez que maintenant la
qualité de la scène est meilleure que
dans les années précédentes
on peut se baigner dans cette scène
c'est ce qu'avait dit le président
Chirac une année mais j'ai constaté
il n'est jamais allé se baigner
chaude et pour moi l'eau de la scène est
trop froide alors bon si jamais elle
était chaude vous iriez ça a été chaud
dans la qualité à l'heure actuelle oui
on pourrait
on n'a pas un s'inquiéter de ce taux qui
a l'air quand même assez incroyable de
pesticides par exemple de toute manière
à l'heure actuelle nos laboratoires sont
elles que l'on détecte de plus en plus
des nouveaux produits chimiques dans
l'eau et on trouvera toujours de nouveau
vous parlez des pesticides on a de plus
en plus conscients
mais les pesticides eux-mêmes ils sont
dans nos nappes phréatique ils sont là
ils ont été mis pour les deux tiers par
nos agriculteurs et pour un tiers par
nos villes ne l'oublions pas mais des
efforts considérables ont été faits dans
nos champs à l'heure actuelle on répend
beaucoup moins de pesticides qu'avant
certes dans le département de Yvelines
nous avons que presque 3% des champs qui
sont en bio c'est à dire strictement
sans pesticides mais de très nombreux
champs sont passés en gestion raisonnée
et en gestion raisonnée on a
90% de la pollution par pesticide enfin
il faut dire que maintenant on n'a pas
le droit de cultiver un champ jusqu'à la
rivière on doit avoir une garde de 5
mètres ce qui permet de ne pas avoir de
pesticides qui aille directement dans
l'eau mais qui passe à travers un
aphrétique je pense que on a fait de
grands progrès mais qui font qu'en fait
justement vous parlez des nappes
phréatiques en 2009 il y avait aussi un
rapport environnemental du plan d'action
nitrate des Yvelines le quatrième plan
qui donnait dans ses conclusions de
rapport que les eaux yvelinoises étaient
en très mauvais état donc pour les citer
l'état des lieux montre que la qualité
générale des unités hydroographique des
Yvelines est mauvaise la masse d'eau
souterraine ont des taux de nitrates et
de produits phytosanitaires critiques
c'est c'était également c'est également
un problème c'est napriatique ce qui est
dit là est vrai sur toute la France et
sur presque toute l'Europe mais la
situation n'est pas si dramatique ça
puisque toute l'eau potable que nous
prenons et nous prenons le nom de la
pratique après un petit traitement elles
sont parfaitement potables il n'y a pas
d'eau non potable dans les Yvelines donc
je dirais que de ce côté là on est quand
même vernis vous soulevez la question de
l'eau domestique justement nous sommes
allés poser la question aux Yvelines
noires au 5 continents plus précisément
pour savoir ce qu'ils pensaient de leur
eau au robinet je vous propose de voir
ça en images
du robinet disons que on la boit pas au
vert j'achète des bouteilles
certainement bonne parce que toute façon
il y a des tests qui sont faits moi je
bois pas de robinet je bois de l'eau que
j'achète au magasin je travaille avec
les enfants à l'école et quand eux ils
boivent l'eau le robinet dans le pichet
c'est toujours un goût des javel oui
tout à fait on la boire régulièrement
mais on achète aussi de l'eau minérale
pour pour la machine à café ou pour les
enfants je ne la bois pas vu mon âge il
me faut une eau avec calcium truc machin
voilà mais je sais pas il y a un goût un
goût un peu de de métal dans dans
l'autre commune convenable à l'occasion
on peut la boire et
on fait la cuisine avec et tout on n'a
pas à s'en plaindre
qui a été réalisé à voisins les qualités
de l'eau elle varie dans le département
évidemment suivant les communes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire de cette
audio robinet elles sont partout
potables heureusement mais il y a des
petites différences dans le nord des
Yvelines par exemple l'eau est plus
calcaire que dans le sud donc il y a des
petits des petits écarts mais sans toute
portables une des dames interviewée
parler d'un petit goût d'eau de Javel
c'est vrai que pour protéger l'eau du
robinet contre n'importe quelle bandit
qui mettrait des produits dans l'eau on
préfère avoir une protection bactérienne
et on met un petit peu de chlore tous
ces petites goutte d'eau de Javel mais
si vous mettez votre carafe d'eau dans
le réfrigérateur et vous la prenez
fraîche après cette petit goût disparaît
complètement et alors simplement pour le
détail pourquoi est-ce que certains ont
ce goût de chlore et d'autre part parce
que ça dépend simplement du dosage qui a
été fait ou si on a traité un peu mieux
l'eau chez soi pour la laisser reposer
un tout petit peu elle est pas au même
prix pas tout non plus cette odeur oui
parce que ça c'est dû au fait que les
impôts que l'on préserve sur l'eau sont
différents dans les Yvelines en gros le
prix de l'eau varie de
2,50m3 à 5 euros vous voyez ça valait du
simple double mais c'est quand même
assez éleveillant au niveau national
c'est élevé au niveau national mais 5
euros pour 1000 litres d'eau vous payez
combien votre eau dans le supermarché
alors qu'en qualité franchement elle est
équivalente c'est rien 5 euros le mètre
cube d'eau c'est vraiment pas grand
chose mais avec ces prélèvements ça nous
permet de bâtir nos stations d'épuration
de travailler et de faire les
investissements pour que l'eau de nos
rivières soit tous les jours plus belle
et en adéquation avec l'environnement
que l'on souhaite prendre le département
et puis cette eau vous me disiez que
elle va peut-être pas baisser au
contraire elle va peut-être augmenter en
tarif je crois que nos chimistes sont
brillants tous les ans ils sont capables
de trouver de nouvelles substances qui
sont dans l'eau d'où de nouveau défi et
de nouveaux défis il faut enlever de
nouveaux produits et tout ça va coûter
de l'argent alors je pense qu'à terme la
tendance est lourde oui le prix de l'eau
ne peut que monter parce qu'on va avoir
de plus en plus de produits qui sont
blancs qui peuvent être nocifs quels
sont les actions quand pour en revenir
au document que vous avez tous validés
finalement qui sont mises en place
quelles actions met en place pour
protéger alors moi j'ai vu qu'on
essayait de renaturer les rivières c'est
ça ça c'est vrai on va essayer de
renaturer les rivières parce que les
rivières ont la possibilité de faire une
auto-épuration alors il faut favoriser
cette autoopération et départements des
Yvelines va consacrer des sommes
importantes dans ce domaine là et puis
non seulement il faut que nos stations
d'épurations soient correctes mais il
faut avoir toutes les tuyauteries qui
amènent toute l'eau usées à nos stations
et là il y a beaucoup de progrès à faire
il faut éviter des fuites d'eau usées au
niveau de la nappe phréatique parce que
là on pollue énormément à ce moment là
voilà il y a quand même beaucoup
d'avenir pour l'eau l'eau les Yvelines
est excellente et on emboîte jamais
assez merci beaucoup quelle mise en
scène pour cette conclusion parfaite
merci à vous